the Iran deal is over bob ayatollah bob
ayatollah i cannot take any more winning
cannot take it at all
president Trump announced today that the
United States is withdrawing from the
Iranian nuclear deal torching the sole
foreign policy achievement of Barack
Obama and relegating mr. Obama's entire
legacy to the dustbin of history oh oh
oh that is so mmm all those are salty
those are good those taste just is that
is that a hint of that would be John
Kerry that's a taste of John Kerry's
tears we will analyse this excellent
move then more good news out of the
federal government shockingly showing up
on time and under budget
finally antipope Rihanna shows up in a
bedazzled cassock and mitre to last
night's Met Gala heavenly bodies fashion
and the Catholic imagination we will
discuss the danger this poses to the
culture but not the danger there Iran
poses because we scrapped the nuclear
deal on Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
what a day what a day I there is so much
- I can't even I'm spilling my coffee
all over the place you can see in my
notes before we get to any of that uh
you know in back in the old
administration I felt like I was losing
my hair because I was pulling it out you
know because it was so terrible how's
that for a segue Sonia is that good but
but now I don't have to worry about that
because of a wonderful sponsor keeps we
have keeps keeps is designed for guys
who want to stop hair loss with their
scientific and affordable approach
managed entirely on keeps calm keeps is
the easiest way to stop hair loss before
it's too late does it really work there
are a ton of products that promise to do
everything for you does it really work
yes this one does really works
it keeps offers the only two
fda-approved hair loss products
clinically proven to keep the hair you
have no BS just science is it safe
oh is it safe it's safer than our entire
world is going to be after today it is
completely safe there are generic
versions of medications that have been
around for a long time but now these are
way way cheaper and easier to get so
maybe you've noticed this happens over
time a little less hair than you used to
have most people don't know this but a
hair loss begins in your late 20s and
30s for most guys it happens much
earlier than you think and it's really
easy to stop so you can a a majority of
men start to lose their hair at that
time and if you just stop it if you take
the simple inexpensive steps that you
need to take you can stop that and keep
looking good into the future I am not
exactly an Adonis of a man you know I
been hasn't paid me in months
but I've always had a nice poofy a head
of hair and that's always helped me out
with the ladies so you should do that
too keeps for five minutes in just one
dollar a day you will never have to
worry about a hair loss again getting
started is easy a sign up takes less
than five minutes you answer a few
questions snap a few photos a licensed
doctor remotely reviews your info
recommends the right treatment for you
all without ever leaving your couch
it keeps is just 10 to 35 dollars per
month that is right less than a dollar a
day on average Plus now you get your
first month for free don't say I never
did nothing for you one hell of a deal
for getting to keep your hair there's no
reason to put it off any
longer stop hair loss today the easy way
with keeps goto to start your first
month of treatment for free go to keeps
calm / cough FA Co V Fe Fe on this very
cough FA de ke EPS calm / cough FA Co V
Fe Fe that is a free month of treatment
keeps calm / cough FA keeps here today
hair tomorrow the Iran deal is over here
is president Trump's announcement my
fellow Americans today I want to update
the world on our efforts to prevent Iran
from acquiring a nuclear weapon the
Iranian regime is the leading state
sponsor of terror it exports dangerous
missiles fuels conflicts across the
Middle East and supports terrorist
proxies and militias such as Hezbollah
Hamas the Taliban and al Qaeda over the
years Iran and it's proxies have bombed
American embassies and military
installations murdered hundreds of
American servicemembers and kidnapped
imprisoned and tortured American
citizens the Iranian regime has funded
its long reign of chaos and terror by
plundering the wealth of its own people
he goes on we'll get to more of that
later but I know John Kerry he's so he's
trying so hard he just wants to weigh in
all he's been calling the Iranians he's
been calling his former co-workers and
allies abroad ok that's fine
former Secretary of State John Kerry
what is your comment on this deal
can you kiss a pretty girl baby boy baby
boy can you kiss a pretty girl Tommy
baby oh oh that silly I am G poking out
of love I am G disillusioned
I am wished to enlist in the Foreign
Legion so I may forget take me désolé
there's only Shaquille he Sydney the
mail that gets compromised open these
you'll kill me oh it is so so good I'm
gonna need ten more of these today I
need 10 more leftist years
Tumblr's Colton please so drew is out
today Ben show was early before this
news broke drew is out I'm sure he's
very upset
in his honor I think we have to play the
Clavin Happiness montage in Drew's
absence we're gonna win so much we're
gonna win at every level we're gonna win
economically we're gonna win with the
economy we're gonna win with military
we're gonna win with health care ins for
our veterans
we're gonna win with every single facet
[Music]
what a wonder
we're gonna win so much you may even get
tired of winning yeah you'll say please
please it's too much winning we can't
take it anymore I do pretty oh so pretty
I feel pretty and witty and again we
have to keep winning
[Music]
[Music]
that's for you drew drew is on vacation
it's a Clavin 'less week but turned out
to be a pretty good Clavin this week so
in your absence you know I never
listened to pod save America because I
value the cognitive faculties that I
have but today I'm probably going to
have to make an exception because that's
all those old Obama pod bros it's all
that like sixteen year olds that used to
work in the Obama White House and
destroyed our country they're the ones
who do pod save America oh man I'm gonna
just bring my tumblers to the to the
iPod today and just a just pour them
right into I'm gonna have to obviously
bring in a Maggi hat for Ben tomorrow I
haven't broken that one out for him in a
while but gonna have to bring it in
maybe I'll just buy him his own I'll
just pass him out to everyone here at
the Daily wire this is so so good I
might sprout a John Bolton mustache just
to celebrate I might will it in just all
the cough FA forces in me to pop out of
John Bolton mustache the Iran deal was
terrible it was terrible don't believe
what the lefties tell you on Twitter
today
it was terrible practically and it was
terrible symbolically it was terrible
practically because it paved the way for
Iran to have a nuclear weapon and it was
so weak it was so we just gave them a
bunch of money that's basically what the
deal I'll explain the intricacies of the
deal in a little bit it was also
terrible symbolically because it was the
United States just bending over to Iran
after we said for years and years you're
not gonna get a bomb you can't do this
don't do this we'll have a red line
don't when we're and then we just bent
over and gave them all this money and
bowed down so oh yes here take whatever
you want you know it's okay just don't
build a bomb for the next 15 minutes and
then you can build a bomb that's not
what we get now what Donald Trump said
today President Trump in his
announcement is that the United States
no longer makes empty threats oh what a
relief
what a relief the entire Obama age was
oh you better not do this you better not
although I'm gonna be I'm gonna write
you a strongly worded letter I'm gonna
say hey booboo
can we all just admit finally that
Donald Trump is a way way better
president than basically anybody thought
he would be can we all finally admit
that there I bet right now the last anti
Trump conserved
is somewhere in the oak-paneled study of
the Weekly Standard or somewhere and
he's saying yeah sure sure but you know
but this Trump read Baudelaire I don't
does he he is doing so well now you
might be wondering how can Donald Trump
just scrap the Iran deal doesn't he have
to go through Congress or the Senate or
I don't know anybody can't any have to
ask the this person or that person no no
he doesn't he can just scrap it and you
know why he can scrap it because it's
not a treaty now why is it a treaty I
thought it was a treaty doesn't it sound
like a treaty it's an international
agreement between the United States and
another country on pretty important
matters matters of national security
there are other Signet would-be
signatories to this non treaty treaty
but there's a beautiful irony here there
is a beautiful irony this gets to the
Obama rule the current Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo then a congressman
from Kansas in 2015 when the Iran deal
was inked or not quite inked he hated
the Iran deal and he was one of the
biggest critics the State Department
wrote to Pompeo the current Secretary of
State in 2015 and said the joint
comprehensive plan of action that's the
Iran deal the joint comprehensive plan
of action is not a treaty or an
executive agreement and is not a signed
document so what is it if it's not a
treaty it's an executive agreement it's
not a signed document the reason for
that is that it could never get through
the Senate Barack Obama couldn't build
consensus even within his own party he
certainly couldn't get an international
treaty like that where we just surrender
and say Iran build a nuke in 15 minutes
you certainly couldn't get that signed
so they did everything they could to
avoid having any oversight from the
people any oversight from our elected
representatives on the Iran deal now we
should have seen this coming a little
while ago some people did see it coming
when Donald Trump named Pompeo to be
Secretary of State that was a signal
from the White House that this would
happen
notice that he was a major Iran deal
critic apparently his predecessor Rex
Tillerson was a little more open to the
Iran deal he wasn't as
critic of it so when that shift happened
when you brought in Ambassador John
Bolton to be the national security
adviser one of the great critics of the
Iran deal an end of Iran generally as
the threat to the world order when you
brought him in you had to think hmm I
bet this deal isn't very long for this
world
but the Iran deal because it's not a
treaty because treaties need to be
ratified by the Senate the Iran deal can
just be scrapped because Donald Trump
says so and Pompeyo says so and john
bolton says so and every reasonable
american says so this is the Obama rule
this is what makes it that much sweeter
this is what makes the irony's so nice
it's not only do we get rid of this
stupid terrible policy that further
imperils the world order and destroys
American credibility abroad not only do
we scrap that but we add insult to
injury with Barack Obama because the
Obama rule is that which can be enacted
with a pen and a phone can be repealed
with a pen and a phone this was what
Obama would brag about he would brag
about how he was a king how he was a
dictator he would say I don't need to go
through Congress if Congress doesn't
want to enact my policies I've got a pen
and a phone I'll sign executive orders
and I'll just make them instituted by my
godless headless unaccountable
bureaucracies and the bureaucratic
agencies okay that's what you can do
that ain't gonna have legs and now
there's there is no more Obama legacy
what's left what is left of the Obama
legacy after the Iran deal is gutted
Obamacare has been gutted it hasn't been
officially repealed but the individual
mandate the sticking point of Obamacare
the the government saying you have to
pay this penalty or tax or a tax when
it's not a penalty or blah blah blah you
got to pay us you got to buy a product
from a private company that's gone
trumps snuck that into the tax reform
plan so that that's gone Obama cares
gutted the death spiral has been
accelerated the clean power plan a
signature Obama EPA achievement gutted
the Iran deal gutted
Supreme Court balance totally preserved
Antonin Scalia died unfortunately but we
got this new guy in his place who's an
originalist on the court the balance of
the court would have totally been in
disarray it had Donald Trump now won the
presidency would have preserved a lot of
Obama era policies and
priorities that didn't happen the
transgender military experiment that
existed for 15 minutes you know that
they didn't exist for most of Barack
Obama's presidency and then he decided
to poke a finger in the eye of Americans
because he believes that the only thing
that matters in the United States are
the handful of people who suffer from
gender confusion and we need to tailor
all of our priorities as a country to
eliminating biological sexual
differences that's over offshore Arctic
oil drilling offshore drilling Antarctic
oil drilling that's back on government
regulation of the Internet and the so
called net neutrality
that's over how about the Paris climate
want to be treating another fake treaty
that Barack Obama knew he couldn't get
through so he had to sort of ante
constitutionally sign this agreement
what about that oh we're out of that one
too what's left what is left it's the
end of the Obama legacy it is as if the
man were not president it's over it's
over today mark it on your calendars
folks it's done John Kerry now the
Barack Obama's Secretary of State the
one of the most boring men in the world
when he's not spending time just
standing on his yacht calling to Teresa
Hinze as a monkey bring me my my time
monkey mm-hmm when he's not doing that
he's not just being Thurston Howell the
third on Gilligan's Island he has been
working overtime to try to save this
deal he's been calling foreign leaders
he's been calling the leaders of Iran
all the people who used to work with
overseas when he was Secretary of State
he met with the Iranian Foreign Minister
Javad Zarif to try to save this deal I
know you're confused you would say wait
a second why is he doing this when he's
not the Secretary of State and he not
only that he doesn't hold any position
in our government oh because he's a big
jerk who thinks too highly of himself
and really wants to salvage any even
slight vestige of a legacy for him or
for Barack Obama or for Hillary Clinton
but they can't cuz it's over hah hah hah
hah hah hah
so he's meeting with these people and
he's meeting with adversaries of the
United States and he's negotiating
behind the back of the US government not
only is this sort of uncouth not only is
this a little bit gauche
and disrespectful of your current
administration and your current
government it's illegal it is illegal in
the Logan Act we'll get to that in a
second of course
in typical trumpian form the president
responded via Twitter Donald Trump wrote
quote the United States does not need
John Kerry's possibly illegal shadow
diplomacy on the very badly negotiated
Iran deal he was the one that created
this mess in the first place that's
right and it reminds you of like a
little kid this is what John Kerry and
the Obama people are doing now there is
a little kid and he was playing around
where he shouldn't have been and he
broke the cookie jar and he smashed the
vaz or whatever and he's trying to clean
it up really quick before you notice
he's trying on they want man they won't
notice if I do it really except except
we did notice your legacy is terrible
you've been at a net negative for the
country sorry try again you can't try
again it's over you had a bad career you
did you did bad you failed at your job
and now Donald Trump is cleaning up your
mess and doing it very well
so what he did here what John Kerry is
clearly doing is violating the Logan Act
the Logan Act was passed in 1799 it
criminalizes unauthorized persons from
negotiating with foreign governments
that have a dispute with the United
States makes sense there's a reason that
this law was passed very early on in our
nation's history almost immediately is
you can't possibly have that can you you
can't have a government negotiating
deals and then have the opposition party
you can't have the Republican
administration governing the country and
in the world because the United States
is a leader of the free world and then
behind their backs you have Democrats
saying hey don't listen to them yeah
don't we're gonna kick them out in a few
years and then you deal with that so
don't listen to them that would that
would destroy the United States a house
divided against itself cannot stand
wise man said that and and then other
wise men quoted that you can't possibly
have that so it's an important law this
is what they booked Mike Flynn on this
is how they got former Trump national
security adviser for four also about 15
minutes Mike Flynn they got him on the
Logan act because the incoming national
security adviser talked with his
counterparts overseas during the
transition
a perfectly normal practice they decided
to go after him on the Logan act and and
try to get him on this what John Kerry
is doing right now up until two hours
ago it's way way worse than anything
Mike Flynn did with regard to the Logan
Act the trouble here of course is that
no one has ever been convicted of
violating the Logan act since it was
passed in 1799
so we partisans always use this as a
threat they always said when it's I've
done it too it's a good little thing to
point out because it is a good law so
you actually do need to watch out for it
but no one's actually gonna get
prosecuted for it the the law started
because President Adams John Adams
didn't like France very much which is a
good American tradition so a Jefferson
loyalist George Logan of Philadelphia
went to Paris in 1798 to get around the
Federalists administration
yeah the Federalists Adams you had the
anti-federalists led by Jefferson and
the anti-federalists sent some people to
Paris and said don't don't negotiate
with the Federalists that's not good I I
totally understand why that law was
passed as a matter of politics we
probably don't want to prosecute people
for it it would just get pretty messy if
you have your political opponents
talking with people overseas and you
start throwing your political opponents
in jail it just doesn't look good even
if they deserve it even if they're
Hillary Clinton frankly it's not a great
look to throw your political opponents
in jail no matter how criminal they are
and how much they deserve it so it's I
suppose it's a good thing we don't
prosecute people for this but important
to keep in mind because John Kerry is
violating this it is an important law it
is really horrible what he's doing it's
very disrespectful it's very
anti-american
but hey we're talking about John Kerry
we're talking about John Kerry who just
speaks in French on his yacht to to
little monkey you know monkey at all
bring me my bring me my Tom Collins
so not just John Kerry's upset about
this Barack Obama's flacks the people
who were 14 years old when they worked
in the White House now they're 16 years
old they're also very very sad the one
that this one came out I believe from
ben rhoades quote beyond the potentially
catastrophic consequences with Iran
Trump's decision is devastating to us
credibility globally after this why
would anyone trust an international
agreement that the u.s. negotiates you
jerks
that's what knows that's what he tweeted
out former he was like a failed novelist
this guy he was in a master's program
for fiction writing and for some reason
he came to determine foreign policy for
the United States under Barack Obama I
think he drove a van one time for the
Obama campaign so he was promoted to
this major presidential adviser are you
kidding me or you kid you're gonna talk
to me Ben Rhodes about the credibility
of the United States you're gonna talk
to me Obama administration officials
about international credibility the
United States the Obama administration's
the President himself not just Aflac not
just a one of you the President himself
said we have a red line we're drawing a
red line in Syria and there will be dire
consequences if Russia if Syria crosses
that red line and guess what Syria did
they said well Barack Obama you look
like kind of a wimp so we're gonna cross
it what are you gonna do and Obama said
mmm I'm gonna write you a strongly
worded letter that's what I'm gonna do
pathetic absolutely pathetic are you
kidding me you people people who allow
the international community people who
allow our foreign adversaries little
tin-pot dictator x' in the middle of
nowhere they when they allow them to
push us around to and we stand down and
we don't back up our threats those are
the people that are gonna tell us about
us credibility give me a break getting
rid of the Iran deal is finally
restoring us credibility abroad it's
finally saying no we're not going to
allow the the worst regime on planet
earth we're not going to allow and look
there are other crazier regimes like
North Korea's that kind of crazier
regime but it's a threat to the world
order as a persistent constant threat to
the world order nobody touches Iran and
we're gonna let the okay you can have a
nuclear weapon but hey we'll only give
you a nuclear weapon if we can give you
a ton of money - that was the deal
basically finally we're restoring
credibility and by the way mr. Rhodes
what about what what in turn
Raymond are you talking about what why
would they get into an international
agreement with the United States I
thought this wasn't an international
agreement I thought this wasn't a
binding agreement I thought this wasn't
a treaty I thought this wasn't an
executive agreement it's just a thing
right it's because that's that's the way
the Obama administration sold it because
what their actions were patently
anti-constitutional you can't have it
both ways
you cannot have it both ways it can't be
a binding treaty that the United States
committed itself to when it's convenient
for the Obama people and then oh just a
thing that nobody actually had to sign
because we don't want to go through the
Senate on the other hand you can't have
it both ways
another Obama flack Dan Pfeiffer tweeted
quote pulling out of the Iran deal will
make all that trumpets feel good but
what is the plan now to contain the
Iranian nuclear threat huh it doesn't
seem like anyone in the White House has
even thought past today's event this is
another one of the Obama pod Bros he's
one of the people on pod save America
that I've been saving my brain from by
not listening to but I'm gonna have to
listen today because it's gonna be the
biggest wine fest ever it's gonna be the
biggest wine fest since November 8th
2016 but through mr. Pfeiffer's
suggestion that nobody in the White
House has thought about how to prevent
the Iranian bomb after the Iran deal is
scrapped pretty sure someone has if
memory serves correctly the national
security adviser to President Trump john
bolton published while the iran deal was
being finalized while all people of good
sense were protesting this stupid deal
he published an op-ed in the New York
Times titled
to stop Iran's bomb bomb Iran seems like
someone's thought of it doesn't sound
like a bad idea either and by the way
that was the headline that was written
it's a good piece it's a more nuanced
piece just like all things with John
Bolton the headline always sounds crazy
and then you actually read anything
about it and you realize this is an
extremely nuanced thinker who knows much
more than you do about these topics that
people spout off on but to stop Iran's
bomb bomb Iran is an important statement
because it doesn't mean that we're gonna
launch a massive war with Iran it
doesn't mean that we're going to invade
Iran doesn't even quite mean that we're
going to bomb Iran necess
Sara Lee what it means is that we're not
going to appease Iran and we're going to
have the credible threat of violence
against them if they continue to
threaten the world order and this is to
ensure world peace simple-minded people
pacifist type people they say oh if you
if you threaten violence that that
threatens the world order not true when
you when you have strength when you come
to adversaries from a position of
strength you can have peace the the
Reagan years were they his critics said
they were bellicose he was saber
rattling he was threatening war was a
madman there were some of the most
peaceful years in recent history
they Reagan administration both terms
peace when you come when you come to an
adversary and you say I'm not going to
fight I don't want to fight please don't
make me fight that creates chaos that
creates war you have peace through
strength and you have chaos and war
through appeasement appeasing Iran
threatens the World Order and it
threatens the World Order in a very
specific way I'm not just speaking in
ethereal terms we have kept a lid on
nuclear weapons for a very long time
we've been using nuclear weapons since
the 1940s and we've been developing them
we've been trying to develop them for
for a long time and we used them in the
Second World War we've been able to keep
a lid on nukes since then and now would
stand to reason if the United States has
nuclear weapons if the Soviet Union had
nuclear weapons pretty soon everybody
would have nuclear weapons that's what
people expected but that's not what
happened right now the countries that
possess nuclear weapons are the United
States Russia the UK France China India
Israel Pakistan now other other country
and North Korea other countries have
actually denuclearized they've had nukes
and then they've gotten rid of them
South Africa
the former Soviet republics like Belarus
Kazakhstan Ukraine but they've actually
denuclearized and we've kept nukes away
from the other countries we've just said
you're not gonna do it we're gonna keep
a hold on it for as long as we can we've
done a very good job for six seven
decades Iran threatens all of this
because if we allow we permit Iran the
greatest threat to the world order it's
always got one foot in the world order
one foot funding
terrorism abroad if we allow them to
have a nuclear weapon you can't every
other country is going to demand this
every other country around the world is
going to demand these things despite
what the Obama Bros and the pod Bros and
John Kerry thinks this is great news so
very quickly what did the Iran deal do
well it was sold to us as reducing
Iran's ability to produce plutonium and
uranium to components used in nuclear
weapons didn't do that there's also a
sunset clause that would ease the
restrictions over time so at best even
if Iran was a straight player it would
delay the program slightly but we know
from the recent presentation in Israel
it didn't even really do that the
Iranians are liars they lied to us they
did have a secret program nobody can
trust them especially on this issue so
in return that's what we get is
basically nothing in return maybe at
best a slight delay in the nuclear bomb
for Iran at best in return we gave them
a ton of money we lifted massive
sanctions from them we unfroze between
50 and 150 billion dollars of Iranian
assets in banks throughout the US and
overseas and then to top it all off we
sent an airplane carrying 1.7 billion
dollars in cash euros Swiss francs other
currencies we just flew it to Iran and
just gave them cash that was our
negotiation we pretend that Iran doesn't
have a nuclear program that they're
trustworthy enough to to be to be
trusted to work with here even though we
know definitively that they've been
lying to us about the nuclear program
they already have we at best slightly
delay the bomb in return we give them
gazillions of dollars that took two
years to negotiate that took two years
to say hey would you like a bomb and a
lot of money
you're going to need to give us more
money mmm okay that basically that was a
negotiation by the way Donald Trump
tried to fix this deal he didn't
initially
scrap it altogether or seem determined
to scrap it all together the New York
Times reports Trump negotiated but the
talks collapsed when Trump insisted on
sharp limits on Iran's nuclear
production continuing after the sunset
clause in 2030 under the obama deal
within 12 years Iran gets a bomb Trump
said no way the talks broke down so
Trump has told the Allies we're going to
reinstate all the sanctions we're an
impose
economic penalties we're he told France
first I think this is significant Donald
Trump told his a new BFF his best friend
forever
French president bfff Emmanuel macron I
told him first this is significant
because Francis typically the most
dovish you know they call this is the
flag of the French army was what they
say
the handkerchief white handkerchief
macron has been skittish about the u.s.
withdrawing from the deal and so Trump
it was good he's a good people person he
gets him on board mainstream media's
furious the AP reports breaking Trump to
withdraw from landmark nuclear accord
with Iran dealing blow to u.s. allies
the CNN reports he's withdrawing from
the nuclear deal further isolating
himself from the world then then CNN
reports OPEC official ditching Iran deal
would harm the global economy OPEC is
Iran by the way OPEC is the Organization
of Petroleum Exporting Countries that
includes Iran Iraq Kuwait Saudi Arabia
Venezuela just like some of the worst
places on planet Earth
and so if basically the headline could
read Iran warns ditching Iran deal is
bad fraud breaking well so and by the
way Trump is sending a message with the
timing of this announcement today is
Victory in Europe day today is you it
might have forgotten in the excitement
the New York Times headline in 1945
today the war in Europe is ended
surrender is unconditional VE will be
proclaimed today our troops on Okinawa
game now critics always say oh it's just
a coincidence you're reading too much
into Trump oh you just got lucky it just
happened to be it's just an accident
just a coincidence okay or yeah sure so
either Donald Trump knows what he's
doing or he's a complete idiot buffoon
who just happens to be the luckiest
person in the history of the world the
entire Trump foreign policy promise from
the beginning of the campaign has been
we don't win anymore we need to win we
need to win we need to have more wins
like we had in World War two the last
time we had a major World acknowledged
win so he chooses the anniversary of the
greatest u.s. foreign policy win to
declare this nuclear deal over and to
say we're gonna have peace through
strength seems like a tough Cohen
that's a hard argument to make the u.s.
no longer makes empty threats we've got
some more good news I gotta say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube but we get we
have a really good news and I've got to
give you my my thoughts on the Met Gala
last night guys
look you know you know what's gonna
happen you for those who are already
subscribed thank you very much and
you're very lucky that you can save your
friends and family for those who aren't
subscribed it's $10 a month $100 for
annual membership you get me the Ben
Shapiro show the under Clavin show you
get the conversation the next episode of
the conversation is going to be a little
old me do you hear that
it's like bells chiming birds singing
the next episode of the conversation
featuring me little ol michael Knowles
Tuesday May 15th at 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific I will take all your questions
and easier anxiety by answering live on
air every query that has burned in your
hearts will be resolved best of all it's
an extra hour-long dose of you guessed
it little ol me that's all that anyone
can ask for except for Ben that's the
opposite of what Ben can ask for Plus
Alicia Krauss will be there too she's a
very sweet girl this month's episode
will stream live on Daily wires YouTube
and Facebook pages it will be free for
everyone to watch only subscribers can
ask questions to ask question as a
subscriber log in to our website daily
wire.com head over to the conversation
page to watch the live stream after that
just start typing in the daily wired
chat box I will answer the questions as
they come in for an entire hour
subscribe to get your questions answered
by little ole me Michael Knowles on
Tuesday May 15th 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific join the conversation go over
there right now I'm gonna just guzzle
back some of these so I can make room
for all the new ones that are pouring in
so a little bit more of the John Kerry
variety we'll be right back with
excellent other political news
it's too much today I can't how am I
supposed to go through all of these
leftist tears and I'm gonna be drowning
okay really really good news coming up
right now from the from the federal
government believe it or not under
Donald Trump the federal government has
had a month which was on time and under
budget in April the federal government
had the best budget month in history the
federal government took in five hundred
fifteen billion dollars in taxes it's
only spent only two hundred ninety seven
billion dollars this is a two hundred
eighteen billion dollar surplus it beats
the old record that happened seventeen
years ago of 190 billion
you always hear they talk about the
great budget surpluses of that that's
what they're talking about they're
talking about 2001 we just beat him we
just beat it the surplus surprised CBO
analysts the CBO analysts predicted a
lower lower receipts to the government
and this they said is the result of a
stronger than expected economic growth
listen to that language surprised they'd
surprised the analysts it's stronger
than expected I don't think it's
stronger than expected it's just
stronger than you expected and these
analysts these experts keep telling us
well we all expected this it's
unexpected growth it's unexpected this
no no you just honor you you are not
expecting it because you're not seeing
what's going on because you're still
living in fantasy land 99% certainty
Hillary Clinton's going to win the
election Trump isn't going to appoint an
originalist Trump isn't gonna pull out a
pair of climb it's a climate Accord
Trump isn't going to rip up the Iranian
nuclear deal Trump isn't going to lower
taxes Trump but that's the world so
everything is unexpected to you but an
annex unexpected if you're just
mainlining khofifah every day and that's
what's going on here so on that it's on
time it's under budget this reminds me
of a favorite clip of mine of Donald
Trump from 13 years ago understand a
residential luxury building is far more
complex than an open floor office
building to build much more you have
many more bathrooms you have many more
kitchens you have many more rooms it's
more complex office building is
essentially open space with sub dividers
so I looked at it and I added up some of
my costs
and for Trump World Tower across the
street built not long ago I spent
approximately 250 $8 foots tallest
building tallest residential building in
the world two hundred and fifty eight
dollars and 32 cents a foot I have eight
hundred and seventy one thousand feet it
costs two hundred and twenty five
million dollars to build so you hear
this it goes on Trump keeps talking like
this a lot of people are surprised when
they see that clip because it's Donald
Trump speaking with technical expertise
on something we usually hear because
he's talking about so many things the
Iran deal tax reform Obamacare this that
the other thing and so he speaks in
these broad terms just like all
presidents do they have to speak in
broad terms because they can't nail down
to the my new details on every single
thing we know that building buildings is
something on which Donald Trump has a
technical knowledge technical expertise
so he says so yeah he was being called
to testify before Congress I think Tom
Coburn was who was interviewing him and
he said the UN building renovations were
going way over budget taking way too
long and Trump said oh yeah I'd paid two
hundred ollars a square foot I'd do this
do untanned things Donald Trump is great
he really is expert when it comes to
tangible things that you can put your
your hands around and that's why Donald
Trump even if he lacks precise technical
wonkish knowledge of certain areas of
public policy or economic policy or
foreign policy or whatever he get the
issues where there's a gut reaction his
gut seems to be in the right place on
the Iran deal the Iran deal actually
isn't that complicated because it was
such a terrible deal but he doesn't
maybe he doesn't know the minutiae of
this bank account had to be frozen in
this because it bump up up but he just
could tell this is a bad deal we're
giving Iran money we're allowing them to
have a nuclear weapon over time bad deal
and then they can sort it out there that
those tangible sort of things say oh
yeah do you think do you think we should
give our adversaries the greatest threat
to the world order on planet earth
should we just give them a bunch of
money and nuclear weapons said no it's a
bad deal I don't know a lot of better
ran sounds like a bad
so you you see this again and again and
the mainstream media they're furious
they've turned up the attacks on Donald
Trump over the past few months according
to a new Media Research Center study
God'll of the Media Research Center
Brent Bozell they do excellent work 91%
of Trump coverage on major networks has
been negative specifically of the
evaluative comments 90% negative 39% of
TV network news coverage of Donald Trump
has focused on the scandals the porn
star and the whatever other stuff
they're gonna gin up the fake dossier
whatever 16% an additional 16% of
coverage was on the scandals of Trump
administration officials so some guy
buys an expensive table for his office
that's major Network news all night only
45% of TV network coverage was devoted
to actual issues actual policy issues
that is an insane number 55% was just on
frivolous scandal nonsense
45% the minority of time was spent on
actual policy issues total ginned up
tawdry reality TV scandals that's the
news that's the news for you I'm a
banana facts first democracy dies I'm
that I'm the facts news nonsense they're
tabloid trash incredibly though this is
the incredible thing Trump's job
approval rating actually rose over this
period of time it rose from 37% in
mid-december
to 43% at the end of April and that's
not just selectively picking polls that
are nice to Donald Trump that is broadly
reflected across all public polling now
why is this well we've paid our taxes so
all that scare mongering nonsense about
tax reform that's over and why else cuz
we see the country is doing well you can
just sense it you can just feel it you
can see oh Johnny's not light off oh
okay that's oh this is oh this is kind
of nice man my my wages are increasing
we know the wages are increasing oh
that's good that hasn't happened in a
while additionally public perception of
the direction of the country is at a
ten-year high even CNN admits this this
is the greatest sign of the Apocalypse
some people are saying Donald Trump's a
good president that's a sign of the
Apocalypse maybe CNN is admitting the
truth of
a Republican that is truly the sign of
the apocalypse 57% of Americans the
majority of Americans now say things are
going well that's up from 49% in
February that's a change in just a few
months that's this is the largest
proportion of people in America who say
things are going well in the direction
of the country is in the right place
since January 2007 since the Bush
administration since the beginning of
the last year of the Bush administration
since before the financial crisis since
before that awful nightmare of the
Barack Obama administration this is the
largest proportion of Americans who say
the country is going in the right
direction
which means that all of the Obama
administration was the country going the
wrong direction there's even a surge of
approval among Democrats 40% of
Democrats now say the country is doing
well 40 percent now that number was 25
percent in February that is a 37 point 5
percent surge in the number of Democrats
who thought the country was doing well
in February as I think so now just a few
months later Trump's daily approval
rating from Rasmussen the only polling
firm it still does daily approval is a
between 47 and 51 percent excellent
numbers CNN shows those who approve of
Donald Trump this is a pretty
interesting fact of this survey the
those who approve of Donald Trump
overwhelmingly cite policy for their
positive view the majority of those who
disapprove of Donald Trump cite his
personality or his body language or his
tweets or whatever the people who
approve of Trump say hey look all the
things that matter they're going great
the people who still disapprove of Trump
for now they cite ephemeral nonsense
another poll Huffington Post and YouGov
poll shows that more than half of
Hillary Clinton voters say the country
was better 50 years ago which makes them
deplorable they are now the deplorable
''s there even there is a sense even
among Hillary Clinton voters that
something in recent years is broken
there's a sense that America used to be
better and greater than it has been
recently I choose that word importantly
there is a sense that we need to make
America great again that's among Hillary
Clinton voters that is wonderful news do
we have any time yes in the last because
there's too much good news
so we have to get a little bit of
ridiculous and sad news in we just got
to inject that just so that we're not
like going through the ceiling today I
have to talk about this Met Gala last
night the Met Ball this happens every
year in to support the the Costume
Institute at the Met and it's very big
Hollywood stars come they wear these
crazy costumes designed by all these
amazing designers they're usually quite
beautiful
this year's was titled heavenly bodies
get it fashion and the Catholic
imagination now I would have preferred
heavenly bodies fashion and the Catholic
logical deduction of the nature of
reality but that is a minor semantic
quibble it's neither here nor there this
is the annual show and usually they have
these boring themes so they have
recently they had China through the
looking-glass now you probably can't do
that because that's cultural
appropriation now you know that's fine
as a little boring American woman
fashioning a national identity kind of
bland
they've all been kind of bland recently
the Roman Catholic Church is not bland
there's many things it is not bland
Chesterton described it as a thick steak
a glass of red wine and a good cigar
that the the the aesthetics of the
Catholic Church or the aesthetics of the
West and some of these costumes last
night some of these gowns and costumes
were really quite good Katy Perry's I
loved it it was very it was seraphic it
was she went is this giant angel six
foot tall wings very beautiful it
actually did reflect a Catholic
aesthetic Rihanna took things a little
literally Rihanna was one of the hosts
of this this singer Rihanna you know I'm
sure we're all very familiar with her
her ODEs and you know quartets or
whatever she writes she she just showed
up in a Pope hat so she just wore a
mitre you know and that's but I kind of
liked it and sort of it didn't look good
exactly but it was kind of fun you know
and I don't know I get this I kind of
like Rihanna is a you know she works
with Kanye I kind of like Kanye now she
worked with Paul McCartney that's fun
doesn't seem to take herself super
seriously yeah I kind of liked her and
so but you know she wears this Pope at
is it this
like did I do it right you think well
probably could have done a little better
but that's okay
then it gets to lean aways I don't know
if I'm pronouncing that right she's some
actress that I've never heard of and she
decided that her response to the
Catholic Church she's gonna wear a
rainbow flag cape you know cuz she's a
she's a lesbian I guess and that's her
but yeah now you could say that she was
evoking Joseph's coat of many colors I
don't know if that's quite what she was
going for but either way you know she
wears this this rainbow flag cape and
she's basically saying yeah yeah that'll
show you roman curia that'll show you
church to kind of miss the point it's
not a Catholic aesthetic so okay good
yeah good point
hey you got him sure broadly speaking I
like the idea of this some Catholics
were getting offended they said you know
no you shouldn't make a mockery of this
I don't think it makes a mockery of the
Catholic Church or the Catholic
aesthetic to wear clothing that's
evocative of the Catholic imagination as
they call it I wanted some some
Crusaders to show up wearing the big
cross and the you know chain-link arm or
whatever but the Catholic aesthetic is
the aesthetic of the West the greatest
art in history has been made by the
Catholic faithful Dante Michelangelo
Raphael of people that have last names
that you know a lot of a lot of of the
art of the West is Catholic the majority
of it certainly all comes from the
tradition of Catholicism the culture of
Catholicism the part that's sad about
this is that it's a costume the West now
wears crucifixes and they were people
were wearing big crucifixes they wear
them for costume rather than for worship
and lest I be accused of being like the
cultural appropriation people I'm
actually making the exact opposite of
their argument I'm not saying that you
know my culture is not a costume or my
I'm not saying that at all I'm happy
that they're wearing Catholic aesthetic
garb I'm happy that they're
appropriating the Catholic culture I
just wish they would appropriate the
Catholic cult as well I wish they would
go further in their appropriation
actually because this dinner wasn't or
this this gala wasn't medieval themed it
would be one day
they said fashion and the early church
fashion and the late medieval church
fashion and the Provence all bishops or
what I don't know it was fashion in the
Catholic imagination so it's not just
wearing clothing from a different time
period and saying that's my costume all
clothing that's out of fashion becomes
costume when you wear it I can wear the
armor of a knight I'm not really where
I'm wearing a costume that would always
be a costume but now we're saying
Catholic culture itself is a costume
because we don't do it anymore and this
is not good
this is fundamentally disconnecting the
culture from the cult you can't have a
culture without a cult the culture is
defined by what the people worship so
this this could threaten to transform
modernity into a new Dark Age because
everybody's got to serve somebody and
that is being supplanted by something
the culture that fashioned the West now
where's that that garb as a costume
that's not a good sign
this this poses a lot of threats but
ain't gonna happen today because today
we're fighting back this is a point I'll
try to bring in some Clavin nasir
because Drew's out all week
he always says you just have today if
you have a good day then you have a good
day tomorrow you have fight for liberty
today you preserve Liberty today you
preserve it tomorrow if you do that
enough days you have a good life you can
all we can do is preserve Liberty today
and we have done that the cut of the
United States has done that today this
is a very good day Cheers
I hope you enjoy your John Kerry vintage
2018 salty delicious leftist tears we've
got a great show tomorrow got a really
interesting topic we're gonna take on
well I won't spoil it you'll you'll see
it tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
go feather
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018